guillon du gué fait sa ronde quotidienne
il qualifie sa deuxième saison de pêche
au crabe commun aussi appelé le crabe
des roches comme étant excellente elle
qui a débuté le 1er où chaque jour le
pêcheur navigue près des côtes et retire
des fonds marins ces 75 cage placé à 18
mètres ou 60 pieds de profondeur
vacances guillaume duguay ne s'étonne
pas de voir ses cages fourmiller de
crabes il en récolte généralement 3 mes
livres au quotidien et ce jusqu'à la fin
de la saison qui se termine le 26
septembre pour un grand total de 100 à
150 mille livres de zinc en europe dans
le plus commun nous apprécions un peu un
vidangeur de moyens coûtent ça se
promène dans le fond ça mange vraiment
tout ce qui va traîner dans le fond fait
que danse avons mangé du maquereau ça va
manger les petits coquillages des
étoiles de mer mais ne vont pas tant que
père charre à maquereau il se réjouit
donc de voir la ressource intégré
l'assiette des consommateurs québécois
cette année avec un projet pilote de
promotion du crabe commun qui implique
15 restaurants ce restaurateur constate
déjà un bel enthousiasme auprès de la
population pour découvrir ce crustacé il
qualifie le goût de ce tour tôt comme
étant très fin et plus sucré que le
crabe des neiges mais nous nous qu'est
ce qu'on fait c'est qu'on le fait
bouillir dans l'eau salée comme le crabe
le aux morts je pense que la meilleure
recette pour les fruits de mer puis sa
garde son goût puis on va le servir
qu'un peu de beurre à l'ail comme le
classique selon le programme la
fourchette bleue il s'agit d'une belle
façon pour les amateurs de fruits de mer
du québec de découvrir les richesses
marines vivant chez eux dans le golfe du
saint-laurent le cap commun considéré
par pêches et océans canada comme une
espèce émergentes au québec
l'exploitation commerciale de cette
ressource a débuté en 1988
mais ce n'est qu'à partir de 1995 que la
pêche a pris 1 et sans réel le crabe
commun demeure l'une des proies
préférées au homard c'est pourquoi une
gestion très prudente est justifié pour
prévenir tout surexploitation et
séguillon wellen radio-canada sainte
madeleine de la rivière madeleine